Please welcome the empire,
the icon, the one and only, Christina Tosi!
(audience cheering)
I'm so excited because, I mean, it's just like,
I can't believe the empire you built.
It's really amazing.
And as someone who knows and respects business,
what you have built, Christina, is just like,
oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Really and truly.
So we've gone out and hung out
at great restaurants together,
but we've never actually baked together.
No.
So I brought you
one of our best-selling cakes.
It's one of our iconic cakes, it's the birthday cake.
It's the cake that like reminds you of your childhood,
but that we've deconstructed.
You know, we do all the outside the box stuff.
How do you deconstruct what makes something so like sticky--
Nostalgic.
Yes, and nostalgic.
And how do you bake it up with fresh perspective?
Well, I think we're gonna try something
that we've never done on the show,
which is like you're gonna direct me.
You ready for this?
I'm your actor,
I'm your student, I'm your clay, mold me.
Okay, I'm all yours, Christina.
I am all yours.
You're all mine.
Okay, so the birthday cake,
we don't frost it on the sides,
because there is so much like thought,
and emotion and process into it,
we don't wanna hide it behind frosting.
I like frosting just as much as anyone else,
but that's why we don't frost the sides of our cakes.
I hear that.
Why annihilate all the hard work you've done
by covering it up?
Also I just wanna say,
frosting the sides of a cake perfectly is a very hard thing.
So I'm setting you up for success.
Good, okay, great.
Okay, so birthday cake,
I already baked the actual cake sponge,
but you're gonna cut out rounds.
That's right.
This is a six-inch cake and we make it at all the bakeries.
We ship it to doorsteps all across the country.
And this is it, for good days, for bad days,
for birthdays, and everything in between.
Exactly, so that's the round.
You can use this
to pull it out.
Palette knife.
The palette knife.
She's got it.
What's this called again?
An offset spatula.
Offset, thank you.
Is what the pastry dorks call it.
Yes.
You got it.
Bring it on over here.
Boom.
You got it, oh, I'm so impressed, look at you.
I'm about to screw it up.
I know it.
The focus.
No, you got it.
Ah!
You got it!
And then, look!
No, you did it!
(audience clapping)
Ra!
And then, you give it exactly a little pat down from here.
So we take the cake soak.
Are you ready for this?
This you have to make into a perfume.
I feel like this is right up your alley.
So you've got the cake sponge.
Then we soak it by making a little bit
of birthday cake soak.
Are you ready to smell this?
It's a little bit of clear
vanilla extract and milk.
Oh my god!
It smells like the bottom of a cereal bowl
after like Fruity Pebbles.
Yeah, it's a little bit
of like just get a little in here.
Right?
You're right.
It would make a perfect perfume.
So a little bit of cake soak,
that's moisture and flavor.
And then, you ready for this?
You would thrive in a kitchen.
So you do birthday frosting.
We spread that around.
I'm gonna do that, I take, you ready for this?
The cheapest spoon,
and I use it as my palette knife
when I don't have a palette knife.
You know, just in case it's in the washer.
I love that you just bent the neck of the spoon.
Just bend the neck of a spoon, come on, girl power!
Some birthday crumbs.
And then, you're gonna come on top with another cake round.
Look at you go, Drew, Drew, Drew, Drew!
Drew, Drew, Drew, Drew, Drew!
You got it, you got this,
you got this, you got this.
It's real tight.
It's real tight!
You got this!
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom!
Perfect, get it down, get it down there!
Bend that spoon!
Oh, wow.
Look, you got it!
Oh my gosh.
And you just nestle it in.
It's sort of like gluing layers of cake in between frosting.
Okay, I did it.
And then, you do
a little bit of frosting on top.
Okay.
And then, once the frosting on top gets smoothed out,
we throw it in the freezer to set all the layers.
But you get in there with your spoon, yeah.
(upbeat music)